today on the Matt wall show the drag
queen grooming events are only getting
more outrageous and perverse as two
recent incident shows so what can be
done to put a stop to this we'll discuss
today also George Floyd's family
threatens to sue Kanye West for saying
that George Floyd died from overdose
somebody plastered the gender studies
department at the University of
Wisconsin with posters advertising my
upcoming event on campus students in the
department say that it's a hate crime I
say if it's a hate crime it's a
hilarious one Stacy Abrams has an idea
for fixing the economy kill more people
and late night host James Corden is
exposed as yet another pompous Hollywood
jerk no big surprise there all of that
and more today on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
can be scary checking for monsters under
your kid's bed the Indescribable pain of
stepping on Legos but one thing that
doesn't have to be scary is getting life
insurance fabric by Gerber life was
designed by parents for four parents to
help you get a high quality surprisingly
affordable term life insurance policy in
less than 10 minutes Fabrics new lower
prices mean significant savings over
other providers with great quality uh
quality policies like a million dollars
in coverage for less than a dollar a day
life insurance can have a bad rap for
being complicated but fabric makes it
easy to apply with its seamless digital
experience it's all online and on your
time and if you need extra support
Fabrics team of licensed insurance
agents can answer questions along the
way it takes less than 10 minutes to
apply see your quote and then
personalize your quote to fit your
family's needs you can be offered
coverage instantly with no Health exam
required with over 1600 five-star
reviews on trustpilot.com you can feel
confident that you're getting a high
quality policy that is perfect for your
family fabric has a 30-day money-back
guarantee you can cancel at any time so
protect your family today with fabric by
Gerber Life apply today in just 10
minutes at meatfabric.com Walsh that's
meatfabric.com Welsh m-e-e-t fabric.com
Walsh policy is issued by Western
Southern life insurance company not
available in certain States price is
subject to underwriting and health
questions
well you know it becomes quite wearying
to hear about atrocities like this but
the worst thing we could do is get bored
of it and just stop paying attention so
we begin with footage of another all
ages drag show quote unquote in Texas
attended and documented by Sarah
Gonzalez of the blaze she says that she
has more footage on the way but the
30-second clip that she posted yesterday
is shocking enough on its own it shows a
man in drag lifting up his skirt and
gyrating around while people throw money
at him and in the background you can see
a child who can't be more than I don't
know six or seven years old
looking on confused and obviously
completely Disturbed meanwhile the music
which is blasting through the restaurant
is
so vulgar and sexual that I can't play
the the clip with sound and I can't even
quote the lyrics to All I can say is
that it's a woman wrapping an extremely
graphic terms about her genitals and
about the various sex acts that she
wants to perform
so there's at least one child in the
building
listening to that while watching a
cross-dressing man dance around with his
skirt pulled up to reveal the women's
underwear underneath
this is happening in Texas
I feel like we can't emphasize that
enough that so many of these things so
much so much of this footage that we're
getting it's from Texas
it's this bad in Texas so we can be sure
that it's even worse pretty much
everywhere else in the country
especially in a place like Oregon where
as Andy know reports for the
post-millennial a bar is uh planning a
drag show this coming weekend featuring
an 11 year old performer and it gets
worse read it from the article it says
controversy has erupted after a pub in
Eugene Oregon announced it is hosting a
drag queen event featuring an 11 year
old child an investigation by the
post-millennial has revealed that one of
the child's drag Moms quote unquote was
recently charged with child sex abuse
offenses
uh quote are you excited for drag queen
Story Time brunch this Sunday morning
old Nick's Pub asked in a Facebook
announcement Vanellope is here to show
you what a what an 11 year old drag
queen can do
the post featured several photos of
Vanellope craving McPherson
Vanellope craving McPherson Dupont
that's the stage name of the child
including one where she is touching her
chest and her mouth is open the post
millennial is not publishing the real
name of the child old Nick's Pub is
known locally in the University Town for
being a leftist bar and it frequently
hosts drag shows as well as sexual
fetish events Vanellope has performed at
different events around the state of
Oregon sometimes with grown male
performers and risque outfits since at
least 2018. the girl has cash app and
venmo accounts where adults often send
her cash tips
photographs on our Facebook page also
show her being showered on stage with
dollar bills
by the way as you may note there this
article and others that I've read about
this uh refer to the child as her but if
this is a drag queen then you'd think
that means the child is actually a boy
unless they've now started dressing
little girls up like drag queens too
which maybe they have I'm not sure
what's the case here but either way
whether a girl or a boy
drag is an inherently sexualized
burlesque performance and there is no
Universe in which it would be acceptable
to include children either male or
female in such a spectacle in any
capacity whether as Spectators or
especially as performers
continuing on it says vanellope's
Handler
Jennifer Hibbs is also her drag mom
she uses a stage name Sunshine Ray
McPherson and is a longtime lgbtq
activist Hibbs clarified she is not the
girl's parent or Guardian as previously
reported but is the Handler for the
child
quote her actual mother does her
choreography so that it's all
appropriate hibb said we wouldn't let
her do anything suggest suggestive
terrible that people assume that we
would let her do that
we're the terrible ones you see not the
adults who are sexualizing and taking
advantage of a child we're the terrible
ones it's our assumptions that are
terrible
but here's another important detail from
those reported says on August 11th
vanellope's other long-term drag mom
Kelsey M Boren who uses the stage name
always craving was arrested in Lane
County and charged with 12 felonies
related to making and distributing child
porn brought prosecutors found the 32
year old such a danger to the public
that they successfully petitioned the
judge to deny her bail at the time of
her arrest Boren was a teaching
assistant for a special education
student at vannetta Elementary in
vanilla Vanetta Oregon
she allegedly told detectives that her
need for child porn was like a quote
uncontrollable itch that she couldn't
stop
now
a few things here are confusing well
more than a few things but focusing just
on on these for a moment for one thing
the pronoun situation is all over the
map okay it's not clear of the various
people mentioned here which are actually
females though they all use female
pronouns I mean it doesn't really make a
difference I suppose the child is being
exploited either way the adults are
creeps and degenerates and worse either
way
um but that is a confusing aspect of
this also I was not previously familiar
with the term drag mom
though from Context it seems that this
is just another way of describing a
professional groomer
the uh quote drag child is handed over
to the drag mom to be groomed and
conditioned it seems to be essentially a
sort of pedophilic predatory farm system
that the groomers have set up
so
what can be done about this that's
really the question
we've established that this is happening
and it's only getting worse over time
progressivism does what the name
suggests what the label suggests it's
progressivism so it progresses except
that it progresses in the same sense
that say cancer progresses it keeps
spreading and getting worse and eating
away at our civilization until it is
stopped
or until it destroys its host
and just like cancer stopping it
is not a gentle or a painless process
the farther along the cancer is the more
aggressive you have to be in fighting it
culturally we are approaching if we
haven't already reached a terminal state
which means we have to be all the more
aggressive which calls for two things
first
obviously
involving children in drag events in any
capacity
should be outright criminalized
everywhere there is no other way you
know this doesn't stop until police are
breaking down the doors of these places
and carting the adults away in handcuffs
charge them all as pedophiles throw them
in prison and and whenever they get out
if they do get out put them on the sex
offender registry for life
that man in the first clip dancing
around with his skirt up
should be treated legally as a child
predator
that that's the level of protection that
our children are owed and the people
sexualizing exploiting them are owed
that level of punishment
this is something that needs to start in
red States and if Republicans take over
the White House it should be handled on
the federal level as well I know that um
that republicans in Congress have just
put out a bill that would uh that calls
for the defunding uh you know that
forbids the federal government from
funding or facilitating
the sexualization of children in any
form and that includes you know sexually
explicit material being handed out in
schools that includes drag queen you
know uh drag queen story hours and all
the rest of it
and that's good because certainly we
should not be funding or in any way
facilitating any of that
but we've got to go far beyond that
you know this should all be criminalized
second we don't have to wait for
lawmakers to get their act together
we can act by heaping shame and Scorn on
the adults responsible for this public
shame is an indispensable tool it's one
necessary for a civilized society to
function
but it's one that we have you know
historically become quite shy about
using and when I say we I don't mean the
left because the left they're not shy
about it they'll shame their enemies
without hesitation they'll destroy your
your life and your reputation if they
can so public shame is is their number
one tool it's their most it's their
favorite tool to use
the difference is that they are most
often heaping shame on people who don't
deserve it and they're doing it as a
means of avoiding intellectual
engagement
we on the other hand should be making
social pariahs out of people whose
Behavior warrants it
because we have tolerated far too much
the very people who are the quickest to
wield shame as a weapon
somehow convinced us that we shouldn't
use it ever
oh it's wrong to shame people you can't
shame people
they say well they go around shaming
everyone
the effect is a culture where people can
do the most shameful things without any
shame at all notice how all these places
they you know they they advertise their
child drag queen shows and they're all
Quote all ages drag shows and all the
rest of it
and it's the same story over and over
again they advertise it they put the
Flyers out they put the stuff up on
Facebook they they oftentimes will post
their own videos of these things and
then they start scrambling and panicking
when the backlash comes
now you might think well that's that's
an act they're they're pretending but I
don't think it is an act
they sincerely did not expect any public
outrage because they've been able to do
what they whatever they want for so long
without anyone criticizing them for it
so they assume that that would continue
they have gotten comfortable
far far too comfortable
I would say
and now it's up to us to make them
uncomfortable
now let's get to our five headlines
foreign
with election season upon us
big days are ahead but I can't stop
myself from thinking about the good old
days before the World Went Crazy
pre-pandemic pre-blm pre the alphabet
movement I guess you could say I'm just
missing the good old days which is why I
want to tell you about Legacy box Legacy
box makes reclaiming preserving your
most cherished policies incredibly easy
set in your old VHS and camcorder tapes
films and photos their team sends
everything back on a thumb drive DVD or
Cloud digitally preserving your Memories
Forever each kit includes everything you
need to safely pack and send your
records these Irreplaceable moments can
be easily viewed shared and passed on
for future Generations last year I
refused to uh fix my mother's VCR over
the Thanksgiving holiday something I've
not been allowed to ever forget because
it keeps popping up an ad copy and to
make up for this slight against my dear
sweet mother sweet Grandma Walsh if you
will I got her Legacy box so that she
doesn't have to keep her old VCR around
and more importantly I don't have to fix
it digitalize your memories with Legacy
box grab some popcorn and gather the
family to revisit visit the good old
days plus take advantage of their
special election sale visit lexbox.com
Walsh to shop this incredible deal
exclusive to my listeners that's
legacybox.com Walsh
by the way I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention
to you uh and in fact wish you a happy
pronoun day this is uh this is actually
International
pronoun day it's a day to celebrate
pronouns
um I don't know if there's if there is
an adjective day or a preposition day
I'm not sure about that a verb day but
there is a pronoun day and the LGBT
Foundation whatever that is puts out
this tweet happy International Pro down
pronoun Day to you whether you use Z ZEM
she her day Dem
oh come on
day Dem
d-e-y-d-e-m
so for people with bad grammar you know
if you've got really bad grammar that's
how you say they in them and now we're
just turning that into its own part
because why not you can identify as day
Dem uh he him they them Fey Fair
pronouns or any others uh this is just a
short list of some example pronouns
people may use you'll never know
someone's pronouns until you ask
which means that I will just never know
because I will never ask and you know I
often hear people say
well I I heard this a lot but they say
well well I'm not using these fake
pronouns you know Fey Fair zazam Day Dem
I'm not using that that's ridiculous
I'll call you she if you're a man and
that's how you identify I'll say that
but uh I I draw the line at the rest of
this stuff I'm not gonna do that
no no you don't really draw the line and
and you will start saying it
okay you'll be saying zazam in no time
you'll be walking around respecting
those pronouns yes you will
you'll eat the bugs you'll live in the
Pod you'll say zazam
you'll do all of that if you're willing
to call a man she
okay if you're willing to do that and
you've demonstrated your willingness and
you're willing to go that far
then
it's it's only a matter of time the only
reason that you haven't started saying
FEI fair and zazam is that the social
pressure hasn't yet been intense enough
but when it gets a little bit more
intense and they ratchet the uh and the
you know they turn the heat up a little
bit
trying to Ram the rest of this stuff
through you'll go along with it
if you're willing to go along to begin
with by calling a man she
which like just like we talked about
yesterday that is actually more absurd
anyway it's like to call a man she is
more ridiculous than calling them Zay
ZEM
because at least zazam is like it
doesn't
if you call someone a Zay or a Zen we
can't really say that that's
untrue because it doesn't it doesn't
mean it it's just it's just total
nonsense you're not really you're not so
much participating in a lie you're just
babbling
you're babbling nonsensically on command
which is also not good
but if you call a man she you actually
you're actually participating in a
deception in a lie you're going along
with it you're saying something that is
not true
which I would say arguably is even worse
than simply babbling and coherently so
if you're willing to do that then you
will do the rest of it all right this is
a report from the daily wire it says the
mother of George Floyd's daughter plans
to sue yay West
Kanye West I just I'm sorry I can't go
along with this his name is Kanye
I can't go along with the yay thing
um
anyway plans to suit Kanye West for 250
million dollars following the rap and
fashion mogul's alleged claim that
Floyd's death in 2020 was caused by a
fentanyl overdose her lawyers announced
on Tuesday Wes made the claim after
watching The Daily wire's new
documentary on black lives matter Roxy
Washington said she is suing on behalf
of herself and Gianna Floyd the daughter
she had with George Floyd West who
recently changed his first name from
Kanye implied an interview that aired on
Sunday that the 46 year old Floyd died
from an overdose and not at the hands of
Minneapolis Police Officer Derek Chauvin
who was later convicted of murder west
side of the interview I watched the
Georgia Floyd documentary The Candace
Owens put out one of the things that his
two roommates said was that they want a
tall guy like me and the way that he
died he said a prayer for eight minutes
they hit him with the Fentanyl
Wes was referring to the greatest light
ever salted documentary about Owens that
explored Floyd's death chauvin's
conviction the rise of black lives
matter
the lawsuit will accuse west of making
the comments to promote his Brands and
increase marketing value and revenue for
himself his business partners and
Associates
this is clearly just totally absurd
first of all what Kanye West said is
accurate
um and that is that's the first so there
are a couple of uh of easy defenses
against a defamation claim
and one of those is the truth you know
the truth is an absolute automatic
defense against defamation
if what you're saying if you can
demonstrate that it's true or you know
put it the other way if you want to
accuse someone of defamation you need to
be able to prove that what they're
saying is not true
so that that lets Kanye West off the
hook in this case right off the bat
and then the other thing too there's
another defense
um against uh defamation which is that
if the person is dead
that's also a defense
so here we have Kanye West saying
something accurate about a dead guy
and they think they can sue him for 250
million dollars
uh
go ahead and try I suppose
I mean you can you can sue anyone for
anything in in the United States of
America and uh there as we've seen there
are many people who are
you know who are quite willing to test
that test sort of test that theory out
that you can sue anyone for anything and
you can you can sue anyone for anything
but uh you certainly can't win any
lawsuit in this one they cannot win
all right here's an article from the
badger Herald
it says as the University of Washington
of Wisconsin campus prepares to host
Matt Walsh a right-wing political
commentator
members of the lgbtq and gender
non-conforming communities on campus
have expressed feelings of hurt and
concern recent targeted incidents
towards the group have exacerbated these
emotions
so there have been targeted incidents
the University of Wisconsin I'll be
speaking there I remember the exact date
I'll be speaking there soon as we
continue the uh our what is a woman tour
and we'll be announcing some more dates
by the way and some more schools pretty
soon
but apparently in the lead up to my uh
to my speech and screening the film at
University of Wisconsin there have been
there have been there have been targeted
incidents at vulnerable populations
let's find out what those incidents are
upon arriving at Sterling Hall Monday
October 10th
um
people with the gender women's studies
Department someone named Jessica Leeper
found the gender women's studies floor
covered in posters for the Walsh event
that's the that's the targeted incident
so somebody went in at University of
Wisconsin uh presumably you know a
supporter maybe a member of the sweet
baby gang there at University of
Wisconsin went into the went to the
gender women's studies department and
just and and
covered the place in what is a woman
posters
that is uh I cannot I don't know if I
can officially endorse that or not
but I will because that's fantastic
when Libra first arrived she only saw a
couple of posters and she said she was
annoyed but not surprised but upon
further investigation she found that
every bulletin board and chalkboard in
the hallway had been covered in the
posters I think we have some pictures
we'll put up for you too well while
Libra did not count the exact number of
posters she took down she estimated that
it was at least 40. Libra filed only one
or two event posters in the other
departments in Sterling
so this is this is the incident that
happened
uh continuing along
according to leaper there's a lot of
hurt anger and exhaustion among the TA
students in the department
quote any credibility the university had
and an academic commitment to providing
speakers of diverse opinions is lost in
the wake of Monday's targeted Act of
hate speech it's a target of active
behave speech to just put up a poster
for my event
you know what go back they took them all
down go back and uh I'm calling on the
sweet babe again go go back and put the
posters back just keep putting them back
up there
take them down put them up
hey this is this is fair play because
the left constantly tears down the
posters no matter what campus I go to no
matter where the posters are put up the
leftist come along and tear them down so
this is the game you want to play this
is what we'll play
she continued yav has now with this
action made it abundantly clear that
their goal with bringing Walsh to campus
is to intimidate and endanger the trans
and gender non-conforming community
explain that to me uh Jessica Leeper I
want you to explain and maybe you can
you know maybe you can explain it
but explain in precise detail how you
have been endangered
by seeing a poster by seeing a small
like a piece of paper
a yellow piece of paper that says what
is a woman how does that endanger you
can you can you
can you elaborate I'd like to hear you
elaborate on that
if you can if you can
prove to me
that simply and I don't know how this
would work physically okay I don't know
what the physical mechanism is I I don't
know the science binder but maybe you
can describe it maybe and explain to me
if you can prove to me that simply
seeing the poster will lead directly to
physical harm or death
if you can prove that to me then maybe I
would call I would I would call off the
sweet baby gang and say stop putting the
posters up
I don't want to have you know I I don't
want there to be bodies all over the
place people that have hurt and dying
because they saw a poster so if you can
explain that then I'd love to hear it
um Lee profiled a bias incident report
to the dean of students the report asked
the school to take the incident
seriously as a targeted Act of hate
speech and revoke Yash permission to use
the Great Hall for their event
there has not been any follow-up to the
report at this time
oh and then we have more interviews the
General Studies Professor Department
this is all great a student in the
gender women's studies Department who
wish to remain anonymous due to privacy
and safety concerns said that more than
anything they were concerned for the
safety and well-being of the trans
non-binary and GNC community on campus
uh quote we were already upset about
Walsh with an explicitly anti-trans
project coming to campus and to me the
event organizers bringing their hate
directly to this space just furthers my
concern over the whole event and the
University's ongoing lack of care for
its marginalized students
ah
you know there is uh when you want to
get over a phobia
um
there's well I think what they call
exposure therapy or something like that
but if you're if you're really afraid of
something and this is what they this is
what they tell you in Psychology that uh
the only way to get over the fear is to
just is to be exposed to it like if you
want if you're I have Arachnophobia I
admit I you know it's one of my least
manly qualities I really don't like
spiders if I actually wanted to get over
that I would have to be exposed to a
spider you know maybe have a tarantula
crawling on my hand or something like
that
I feel like that would traumatize me
more but I'm told that that's one way to
get over the phobia and so I guess my
point is that what I would say to the
students at the gender studies
Department the University of Wisconsin
for whatever reason you are afraid of
these posters you have a fear of posters
and I I think for your own sake because
I am concerned about you and I am
worried about your mental health deeply
and so I think the only way to get you
over that fear
is for more and more of these posters to
be put up in the gender studies
department for your own sake
okay there were 40 posters before next
we got to put 100 up
how are you going to go through life
having this fee if if seeing a poster
can can cause you to dissolve into a
puddle
I don't know how you function in life so
I want to help you get over that
you're welcome
some updates now from the culture of
death Eric swalwell tweets this Maga
Republicans want a women want women
arrested for having an abortion this is
what that looks like okay so we tweeted
this
he said Mega Republicans want to arrest
women
and uh so what Eric twalwell did was he
he uh I don't know if he's a director or
producer on this project there's no
credits at the end but he's put together
this skit
of what he imagines it will look like
for you know abortion to be illegal what
the implications will be and let's watch
this get together
you're weird he is weird but cute
gross
Mary Anderson yes I have a warrant for
your arrest rest for what penal code 243
violation unlawful termination of a
pregnancy you've got to be kidding me
that that is my personal business that's
for the courts to decide man your
medical records have been subpoenaed and
Dr Landry's already in custody
no
God you you can't just you will have to
submit to a physical examination
what
no no no one's touching it
man turn them out put your hands behind
your back now why is this happening
love you honeybear
we're just enforcing the law here
elections have consequences
vote Democrat on November 8th stop
Republicans from criminalizing abortion
everywhere
protect women's rights and freedom
please don't do this
uh that's good that's good comedy there
it's a great skit it's a great it's a
great fun skit uh just that's what it is
it's like just total fantasy this so
because here's the thing if they had
actual footage if this was actually
happening somewhere uh and there was
footage of it right they would just show
you that but it's not so instead I have
to they have to put together this this
skit uh and I don't know if you're
listening to the audio podcast of course
and maybe you can follow it all the plot
but uh the the cops do end up pulling
their guns
um they pull their guns out of these are
they bust in the house with their guns
drawn
card this woman away
um
so that is
uh Fantasyland right that's that's the
this skit that they've put together
meanwhile
in in reality like back here in
realityville
things that are actually happening in
that in that world you know like the
universe that we we live in in the
country we live in
okay in that place
there are actually
pro-life activists that are being carted
away in the middle of the night by armed
federal agents so that's a thing that's
actually happening right now in the
United States of America
that's a that's a reality
so I figured me worried about something
I'd be worried more about the reality
also you know there's also the the
reality
of abortion itself
if you were to see footage of that
or see a picture of the aftermath of an
abortion
there's that reality too
Which is far more brutal and terrifying
than anything you just saw in Eric
swalwell skit
and it's also again real
speaking of brutal and terrifying Stacy
Abrams
has an idea for what we can do about
inflation and the economy she knows how
we can solve the problem let's listen to
her
you're running for governor of Georgia
uh I would assume maybe incorrectly but
while abortion is an issue it nowhere
reaches the level of interest of Voters
in terms of the cost of gas
food bread milk things like that what
can a governor what could you do as
governor to alleviate the concerns of
Georgia voters about those livability
daily hourly issues that they're
confronted with but let's be clear
having children is why you're worried
about your price for gas it's why you're
concerned about how much food costs for
women this is not a reductive issue you
can't divorce being forced to carry an
unwanted pregnancy from the economic
realities of having a child and so these
are it's important for us to have both
and conversations we don't have the
luxury of reducing it or separating them
out but we also have to talk about what
a governor can do a governor can address
housing prices a governor can address
the cost of Education a governor can put
money into the pockets of everyday
hard-working Georgians instead of giving
tax cuts to the wealthy that's what I
talk about on the trail and that's
what's resonating but let's not pretend
that women half the population
especially those of childbearing age
they understand that having a child is
absolutely an economic issue it is only
politicians who see it as simply another
cultural conversation it is a real
biological and economic imperative
conversation that women need to have
these people are so cartoonishly evil
uh like comic book villains at this
point not trying to hide it at all
so she's being asked what are you going
to do about the economy how are you
going to help people struggling in the
economy her answer is to kill more
babies
not shocked by that not surprised by it
I know that's their answer
these people are eugenicists that's
always been their answer
that's always been one of the one of
their their primary Arguments for
abortion
is to you know get rid of The Unwanteds
because they're a burden they're a
strain on society and on the economy so
let's just kill them and throw their
bodies away like like literal garbage
so I've always known that but
even so it's uh startling to hear it
said out loud by someone who wants to be
governor of a state
her answer to the economy is to is to
kill more babies so that they're not
being a strained economically and
financially to their to their mothers
so they're kind of there are two ways
you can look at it right
when you've got a struggling economy as
we do
you can work
to make the country more livable for
people
you know you could work to make it
easier for people to live
um
you can do that
or you could just start getting rid of
the people
two approaches
Democrats take the ladder
because they are really truly anti-life
and anti-human
that's not that's not uh just a
pejorative you know that we throw at
them it is actually true they are in
principle anti-human and anti-life they
see it as a bad thing they see it as a
negative thing they see it as a strain
they see they see Life as a problem that
has to be solved
and as far as they're concerned it's a
really easy way to solve it just get rid
of it
I want to play this for you too Stephen
A Smith who really recently has been
leaning into the um race hustling thing
I mean he's not just recently but
especially recently he had some thoughts
about a little sideline temper tantrum
that Tom Brady threw on Sunday Tom Brady
was upset about the way his team was
playing started yelling at his offensive
line and not an uncommon occurrence in
football
people get heated it happens but Stephen
A Smith you saw this and and and he saw
in it
um racial implications let's let's see
how he was managed to pull that out of
the story
um ladies and gentlemen
we need to be consistent
was Tom Brady passionate or was he the
angry white guy
because if that was somebody else doing
what he was doing with his offensive
lineman we would have been talking about
if that was a black man we would have
been talking about his temper we'd have
been talking about the fact that he
might not need to act like that with the
camera's rolling I had no problem with
it whatsoever if Brothers ain't blocking
for you you 45 years old you behind the
center and you're getting smacked around
you damn right you should get in the
face I have no issue with what Tom Brady
did with them whatsoever all I'm trying
to say is that when a black quarterback
does that I don't want to hear nothing
about it since nobody's saying anything
about Tom Brady doing it and I also
don't want to hear about stuff being
overblown he went to rob it crabs
wedding on a Friday night he missed the
walk through
Etc they clearly are not on the same
page they don't seem to have everything
in order if this was somebody now in
that regard there is a Tom Brady
category that's separate and apart from
everybody else the anger part when he's
getting on the offensive lineman no that
everybody should be lumped into there
but in terms of him missing a walk
through uh because he went to the
wedding they foreign
encourages uh Stephen A Smith because he
always has he's babbling incoherently
and he's always got someone else in the
room with him that's the Yes Man and so
he's saying things don't make any sense
and there's someone in the background
you always hear about yep yep right
nothing he says there makes any sense at
all well why why people are criticizing
Tom Brady because he's a white guy what
are you talking about everyone's
criticizing him before I I heard about
it and I don't follow the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers what are you talking about
this is the advantage you have if you're
left is that you don't have there's
there's you know you can decide what
elements of reality you want to
acknowledge
and you can take those little pieces and
then create your own alternative
Universe of course which is what he's
doing here so he's created a universe
where
where white athletes who have temper
tantrums aren't criticized for it
and as though Tom Brady in general is
not doesn't hasn't had his plenty of
critics through his career
um
creating this narrative where we are
quicker we're we're quicker to criticize
a black man especially a black athlete
for being angry than a white man
where if anything
it's the reverse
because because it's always going to be
safer
to to criticize the white guy than the
black guy and the reason for that is
because people like Stephen A Smith
they're looking for a reason to
racialize everything
all right one other
one other story I wanted to mention this
from the daily wires a couple days ago
James Corden has been banned from a top
New York City restaurant by famed
restaurateur Keith McNally who labeled
the TV talk show hosts the most abusive
customer ever and more McNally took
social media blasting the host of The
Late Late Show as a tiny cretan of a man
who had said that he has been 86th as
customer of his restaurant according to
the Daily Mail the term 86 has a number
of possible origin stories
um well who cares about the Guinness the
origin stories of the term 86th the
middle of this article the owner of the
iconic New York Balthazar restaurant
said that uh James Corden is a hugely
gifted comedian but a tiny cretan of man
and the most abusive customer at my
Balthazar server my Balthazar servers
have seen since the restaurant opened 25
years ago and then he goes on to stories
about James Corden being abusive I think
that apparently the restaurant owner has
relented and reversed course and I think
Gordon apologized or something like that
but this is kind of opened up the
floodgates
and now there are all these reports
coming in anecdotes about James Corden
being a miserable a-hole basically
um same thing happened with Ellen
DeGeneres so he's getting the degenerous
treatment right now
and same thing is happening right now
actually with Bill Murray as well for
slightly different reasons so you have
these you have these Hollywood types who
have a brand of being nice and relatable
and Goofy and fun and whatever
that's particularly the case for James
Corden Ellen generous that was their
whole brand
and then you find out that it's just
that it's a brand it's an invention it's
a part that they're playing
which shouldn't be a revelation or a
surprise but somehow for so many people
it is
you know nothing you see on the screen
is necessarily real it might be might be
real but it doesn't have to be and often
it isn't
because it's it's pretty easy to fake
being nice on camera for 60 minutes at a
time especially if you're paid millions
of dollars
well there's one other thing too when I
when I see any story about James Corden
and that is who are the James Corden
fans exactly is anyone a James Corden
fan
Ellen DeGeneres actually had fans there
were people that liked her maybe some
people still do
does James Corden know
see James Corden to me seems like the
Stacy Abrams of Hollywood even they even
look similar they've got a similar look
similar physique and it's just it's been
decided by the media that this person
is a thing now and then you start seeing
them everywhere it's been decided that
they're beloved and popular but nobody
in the public consents to it
the public didn't decide that the public
loves James Corden and state Stacy
Abrams we're told that we do
and then one day sometimes we're told
that we don't anymore
so we were told that we love James
Corden and now the media is saying never
mind you don't love them anymore he's
actually bad
well the same thing ever happened with
Stacy Abrams seems unlikely but we'll
see now let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know fall is in the air and our
friends at Ventura Collective have um
sponsored this episode to make sure that
all of our listeners are accessorizing
their Autumn outfits with premium
watches jewelry sunglasses and more
while other watchmakers have insane uh
markups vincero gives you the look of a
premium lifestyle without breaking the
bank Plus for a limited time only you
get 20 off plus free shipping site-wide
when you use code Walsh at
vincerocollective.com vincero Collective
designs are exceptionally crafted they
make everything in-house and they Source
their own materials everything I've
ordered from them has been really
top-notch vinchero offers many
attractive designs made with surgical
grade stainless steel durable silicon
and a genuine Italian leather straps in
addition to their watches vincero just
launched their commuter bag this bag is
specifically designed to look Sleek
while traveling my favorite feature of
the commuter bag is the luggage
pass-through strap so you can actually
sit it on top of your suitcase
hands-free the chair Collective also
offers iconic sunglass styles with
polarized lenses and 100 UV protection
and if you don't have impeccable style
like myself you should consider vincero
for a holiday gift for someone you love
buy it before they sell it so get 20 off
plus free shipping site-wide with code
Walsh at vincerocollective.com support
this show and use code Walsh at
vincerocollective.com accessorize your
life at an exceptional price with
vincero
Shelby says Matt looks really handsome
today it's distracting well I apologize
for that
um although maybe the distraction is
that you're not wearing your glasses so
let me put those on uh
Vincent Webb says watching John Oliver's
trans episode I was waiting for him to
mention Matt Walsh think he missed his
name on purpose LOL
but got the heat anyway yeah I it it
does seem
like a relatively glaring Omission you
know he spent he spent 30 minutes
talking about the trans issue and
especially what conservatives are saying
about it and uh
what is a woman not mentioned none of
that is mentioned so it does seem like
that's got to be an intentional sort of
uh working around it
but who knows
um
Dr curia says canned laughter is a clear
indicator of a [ __ ] show yeah well it's
not just that it's it's really it's the
laziest thing imaginable uh when you've
got the the laughter you know you've got
the laugh track you're in front of a
live studio audience and you have there
not only to laugh but also to applaud
and um I'm not revealing anything you
probably don't already know that's like
that the audience is also they might
pump in some of the some of these sounds
to enhance it a little bit but they do
have an audience there but the audience
is being directed is being told you know
when they're supposed to react and
encouraged to react and it's it becomes
this crutch now if you're doing a comedy
show
it makes sense to have a live audience
so I get that if you're doing an actual
late night comedy show having a live
audience makes sense it's weird it's
weird when you don't when they did these
late night not that I watched the late
night shows hardly ever but when they
tried to do them without an audience
during covet it was just strange
but that's where you really have to
decide and this is what this is one of
the things this is the John Oliver and
and um Jon Stewart they get away with
this where
it's like they can't decide if they're
if they want to be comedians
or if they want to be these kind of
serious social commentators
and that also allows them to kind of say
whatever they want to think they can
always hide behind being a comedian
now I'm not saying that you can be a
social commentator and make jokes and at
least try to be funny I'm not saying you
can't combine those two things but it's
the style of the show it's done in the
style of a comedy show and then but then
he he launches into a 30-minute
rant about trans rights
um and why do you want the live audience
for that
well it's just so that you have you know
you can you you can throw in your dumb
little punch lines and you have the
candle after but then also again it's
what they're really there for it's not
the laughter because there are very few
jokes
they're really there for the Applause
so John Oliver is a he's a political
pundit that's what he is
and but he makes sure that he speaks in
front of live audiences so that he has
Applause on hand he needs the Applause
there to support whatever he's saying
and it's supposed to kind of trick the
audience at home
because he says something he gets to
some some you know epic point that he
wants to make or that he thinks is epic
or he wants us to see it that way
um and then you've got the Applause of
the background it's supposed to trick
the audience at home into thinking wow
he really made it oh he really took that
he really took that apart
that's that's how we're supposed to
interpret it
um
mallow says
called it yesterday there'd be a daily
cancellation of weebs knew the weebs
couldn't tell Matt was obviously joking
I myself am an anime enjoyer and I knew
immediately he was up to his usual
trolling y'all couldn't keep your mouth
shut
I've seen this weeb's term a few times
in the last few days
what is that you have to explain that to
me maybe I don't want to know
we I I assume from the context of weeb
is someone who watches anime
where do you get the weeb from
I don't really care that much but I have
heard this term a lot I don't understand
it
um
Raymundo says I would unironically watch
Matt reacting to some good old anime DW
already did something like this with
Brett in Star Wars so it wouldn't be
completely off the table right no it is
it's off the table for for me I'm I'm
not going to do that and there are many
people suggesting that I'd be subjected
to that because I know
although you all claim to be in sweet
baby gang uh you still enjoy watching me
suffer it's like one of your favorite
things you're constantly suggesting ways
that I could be made to suffer
let's force him to watch anime let's
tase him let's let's throw him into a
tank with sharks
this is how you treat your cult leader
um
and finally 92 Jeep says
I'm so confused by John leguizamo's
comment because he hated that film so
much he would show up to the set drunk
almost every time because he thought the
film would ruin his career and we're
talking about his his Mario film I guess
in the 90s I didn't I didn't know that
doesn't surprise me
um it but it did ruin his career well I
guess it didn't ruin it because he never
really had one exactly but um to the
extent that he had one it ruined it and
it should have as you all saw on the
show yesterday we witnessed the greatest
thing ever said during a panel
discussion in the history of
self-serving Echo Chambers in spite of
the leftist dribble spewed on stage at
the event a diamond perhaps created by
the immense pressure of the panelist's
cognitive dissonance was formed and it
was this the phrase you can't stop the
Matt Walsh now you can't stop Matt Walsh
it's you can't stop the Matt Walsh
um and you can't it's true I am
inevitable and now like all things I
speak into existence it's on a t-shirt I
made that demand yesterday and just like
that the next day it is on a t-shirt so
you can go to dailywire.com Walsh to get
your you can't stop the Matt Walsh
t-shirt today also the corporate media
agenda means the news is presented in a
biased way you know it I know it we all
know it thankfully there's a way to get
the most important news of the day
without their narrative and that's by
listening to one of the top news
podcasts and morning wire news episodes
are available every morning seven days a
week and they cover stories other media
Outlets won't touch and every Sunday
until the election you can also tune in
to election wire for in-depth coverage
candidate interviews and much more
it's the most important midterm election
in recent history so you're going to
want to stay informed you'll find
morning wire and election wire on Apple
podcast Spotify daily wire Plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts now
let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
we have another crucially important
conversation for the daily cancellation
today and it begins with and I Told You
So as I've been warning for years and as
the news media is now reporting the
proliferation of emojis has caused a
breakdown of communication anguish
confusion despair follow in its wake
here's the New York Post report and
there have actually been a lot of
reports about this in the last few days
I'm just choosing a New York Post but a
lot of reports on the Emoji situation
here's what it says
Jen's ears are calling out the popular
thumbs up emoji for being rude and
hostile even saying they feel attacked
whenever they see it used in the
workplace after a Reddit poster
confessed to being not adult enough to
be comfortable with the thumbs up emoji
reaction others chimed in to agree and
to call out other common emojis such as
the red heart
quote for younger people the thumbs up
emoji is really passive aggressive a 24
year old redditor wrote it's super rude
if someone just sends you a thumbs up
they added so I also had a weird time
adjusting because my workplace is the
same older workers appeared flummoxed by
the reaction noting that they use the
thumbs up in work related chats to
signal I approve or I understood and I
will obey
of course you know side note here is
that none of these people are
questioning why emojis of any kind are
being used in the workplace to begin
with
but the New York Post continues on
Reddit somewhere less offended by the
thumbs up emoji but felt the heart
symbol was actually the most
inappropriate quote to me the heart is
reserved for family and friends and has
a more intimate meaning of Love while
thumbs up is just simple agreeing
comments of one person I actually find a
heart emoji weird for work messages I
use heart emojis for things like when
someone says I got a new kitten or Susie
did a really great job added another
but the heart to many may be falling out
of fashion a survey of 2 000 people
conducted by prospectus Global showed
that a majority of people between the
ages of 16 29 believe that you are
officially old if you use a thumbs up or
heart emoji now apparently this list of
outdated or passive aggressive emojis
also includes according to this study
um it includes the Okay Hand the poop
emoji the cringing face emoji and the
one with a monkey covering its eyes all
those are you're not supposed to use
anymore
and I agree that all of these emojis
should be canceled but so should of
course every other Emoji because if
you're a literate adult
you should not be communicating
with pictures you should be
communicating with words now I realize
that I am a lonely voice on this subject
as a society we have fallen deeply into
the Emojis grasp everyone uses them now
and every day I'm it's like Invasion of
the Body Snatchers because every day
there's another person who I thought was
anti-emoji and I see them tweet
something and they put the Emoji up and
I think E2 like who who who's left the
Emoji Finds Its way into every text or
tweet or email or Facebook post these
days especially every Facebook post in
fact because nobody under the age of 60
uses that platform it is Boomer Central
and Boomers love emojis perhaps more
than anyone else and this I confess it
is honestly one of the great
disappointments and I feel betrayals of
my life
because when people started using emojis
you know when it first became popular
and I began my campaign against them I
assumed that I'd be able to form an
alliance with cranky Boomers who I
figured don't want any kids on their
lawn or any little dumb pictures in
their emails and text messages that's
what I figured what happened but to my
heart Boomers became addicted to the
Emoji unable to resist its siren song
this is part of a now familiar yet I
think still a little understood
phenomenon where the older Generations
though intelligent and having grown up
in a world where people did things like
read books and write in complete
sentences still older Generations
communicate in a bizarrely drunken and
semi-coherent manner online
Emojis all caps misspellings weird
abbreviations
most of all they utilize the Ellipsis
with just Reckless abandon they drop the
dot dot dot at the end of sentences for
no reason and sometimes even in the
middle of sentences giving otherwise
normal statements a weirdly kind of
ominous feel my parents do this all the
time they'll say like they'll type out
uh can't wait to see you on Thanksgiving
dot dot dot
it's just I don't understand it
the point is that I've been left alone
to fight this battle the anti-emoji
voices are almost nowhere to be found
it's just me against the world this is
my Alamo even here at the daily wire
many of my colleagues are profligate
Emoji users my producer Sean sends me
emojis as if to taunt me it goes without
saying that Michael Knowles is an
Unapologetic Emoji Enthusiast the other
hosts are nearly as bad or else they've
Fallen shamefully silent on the issue
altogether Ben Shapiro doesn't use
emojis yet he never rants against them
like I do almost as if he believes that
there are more important things to talk
about which is obviously absurd so it's
left to me to make the anti-emoji case
again as I have many times in the past
and the case boils down to this it's
very simple emojis stifle and dumbed
down human expression by communicating
in pictures we are increasingly losing
our ability to express ourselves through
the written word this is not entirely
something I'm just making up in fact
there has been actual research done
which consistently shows that our
vocabulary is shrinking we know and use
fewer words than we used to we're less
able to convey our thoughts and emotions
through language and this is at least
partly it seems to me because we use
little cartoons as linguistic crutches
we're devolving all the way back to
caveman days as emojis are essentially
just high-tech cave paintings the
written language of primitive man used
to consist of pictures scrawled on the
wall of a cave now our written language
consists of pretty much the same thing
though the medium has changed
now people often defend their Emoji
dependence
by saying that they need for example
the smiley face in order to communicate
that they're happier in a good mood
but that's what that's what words are
for you should be able to convey that
emotional state through the use of
actual language the fact that adults
struggle in this regard is is troubling
to me I mean pick up a history book
sometime read examples of the sorts of
letters and Communications people used
to write to each other back in the old
days even uneducated people if they
could write at all we're often able to
express themselves with great depth
using metaphors and creative adjectives
drawing a picture with language to
communicate their feelings and hopes and
aspirations and fears compare that with
the written communication of Highly
Educated people today online and it's
like me happy smiley face flag Emoji
LMAO
I'm paraphrasing that's basically the
idea now the response to this objection
is that in emoji
is shorthand it's just a way of quickly
making your emotions or your tone clear
to somebody without having to write an
essay but economy of words being able to
convey tone and emotion quickly and
efficiently is also an important skill
and one that the Emoji prevents us from
developing and besides as the as the
controversy documented in the post
clearly shows
the Emoji creates tonal confusion of its
own
is it a passive aggressive thumbs up or
a sincere thumbs up is it a sarcastic
smiley face or a regular smiley face
does the okay hand sign emoji mean that
everything is okay
whether the person using it is a white
supremacist there's no way to know
the Emoji raises more questions than it
answers creates more problems than it
solves
it's our way of avoiding the burden of
writing in complete sentences or we pay
a steep price for our laziness
the price is nothing less than the
collapse of language and eventually of
society itself
or if it's maybe not quite that serious
it is still at least annoying to me
and that should be enough
which is why not for the first time and
likely not for the last emojis and the
people who use them
are canceled and that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block
thanks for watching have a great day
Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]